[Musica]
va beh credo che questo sia il menù più
figo ma più figo da quando faccio video
blog un attimo fa micro tutor e latenti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fa vincere e non ci siamo su work the
tramp ecco bravo io so che voi siete
stupiti di questa cosa anch'io
giorgio ha stupito più che altro nel
fatto che continua a fare i giochi wac
cioè impossibile dunque ragazzi perché
non avesse mai visto un gioco a non
guardare questo video perché non è per
noi
spiegami come ca come posso uccidere
trump con una persona del pubblico che
mi somiglia di capelli cioè piegato ma
chi è questa la cosa dicasi ride ma per
chi evade si sta roba
[Applauso]
la pace può accompagnare solo ma che poi
questa non è una tizia per ragazzi che
volevo vedere di questo gioco e non
posso non aver messo il suo nome è bello
non posso non aver messo la morte per il
ciuffo da emilia sarebbe stata la cosa
più bella il piccione che li caga in
testa ogni cade tipo sempre comunque un
miglior presidente rispettato dal tram
per ragazzi lo sapevo che sapevo che il
ciuffo c'entra qualcosa che avrei
scommesso qualsiasi cosa che il ciuffo
avrebbe avuto un ruolo in tutto questo
comunque ragazze bianco che c'è una
nuvola formano baffi nel cielo mi
spiegate il problema
prova
[Musica]
capisco questo è il padre di non al
dramma come fa essere il padre non è
giusto lui me lo immaginavo diverso il
padre io non al trump nonché fantastico
il gruppo di messicani no fermi come li
buttano il muro in faccia come quelli
che hanno un mutuo mariacci sa cos'è ho
fatto quanto il wac più trash che io
abbia mai fatto conto di quanti non è
violento e questa cosa strana cioè non
citi violento parte l'aquila che
mostravano gioco cestino gasol e mannini
topolino western
avete presente che prima vi ho detto che
non era così violento ecco mi sbagliavo
e vabbè quattro casinò ecco fantastico
come non detto ragazzi è mio e violento
anche questo un po lo so bla bla bla
come fa è uscito con una cassa blog la
blusa menti zecchino d'oro cosa metto a
vita propria io lo sapevo lo sapevo
a vita però nova bella ragazza nata
bellissimo delinque queste ben questo è
il più bello
ditemi voi se non è la scena più bella
che voi abbiate mai visto su un
videogame non ditemelo complimenti
donald la gru la cosa fa a si costruisce
il muro lo sapessi non ve gente anche a
questo
di vista ho previsto i mariachi il succo
che si staccava il muro tutto previsto
che poi ragazzi con quello perché c'è
pacman tra il pubblico se ascoltate bene
il discorso ha senso in realtà sentite
cos'ha da dire proprio blog
mac donald trump a game show fino a
comunque dei capelli migliori dei tuoi
addio che non ci vuole molto brave posso
fare una domanda secondo voi tra il mio
taglio di capelli e quello di ronaldo
trump quale peggio non è questa fermi
plo palla da rugby
il bello è che sta lì a guardarla del
gruppo cos'è sta roba cosa vuoi che sia
iamm placcato arrivato tasca braille
ecco lo sapevo
no non chiamare altra gente fantastic è
il wrestling può accompagnare solo che
poi ce lo vedete mica donald trump
farebbe wrestling
quanti per l'amor di dio eccolo 1l
piedistallo sono sempre le mani di
topolino che si mette di mezzo e vabbè
dove gliele infili quello halo
ingrandisci prix due ragazzi miei ne
manca una che non ho ben capito quale
dovrebbe essere però aveva la cravatta
non è avete fatto che vestito come andrà
di premi o bisogno d'aiuto microfono già
usato per non mi ricordo che dovrebbe
cos'è sta roba poi la knobloch esempio
nelle fante blog seriously perché è un
elefante dovrebbe va bene mi sono
portato nelle fante che va a fuoco si è
mangiato il parrucchino donald s'è
mangiato parrocchie ed è questo un
problema questo problema questo è un
grosso problema esterno che non abbiano
fatto un video gioco del genere tipo su
berlusconi ancora finito 12 su 12
[Applauso]
avevo detto sin dall'inizio che l'aquila
sarebbe stata meglio se riusciamo a fare
un altro videogioco sempre su da trump
visto che è pieno qualcuno che ha voglia
di spiegarmi il perché di questa cosa
anzi no vabbè non importare il casting
va bene ma fermi non so come si combatte
anche grazie light punch quindi ogni più
leggeri ogni più pesanti xn vai ci provo
io che sono fisicato che resti
sicuramente amica a chi è che possa
anche bloccare mica mike tyson può
accompagnare sono destro
la sanguigna love during rage mod
ora la faccia guarda la faccia è bello
appello per il ciuffo agosto
[Musica]
un grande mi piace slappa fa questo
pezzo di puzzle è comunque un presidente
migliore di donando tampa bay ragazzi
tra i due videogames non so quale era
più intelligente mettiamola così è stato
alquanto strano ma va bene quindi
ragazzuoli spero che vi sia piaciuto
cose il suo bisogno al momento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook con
descrizione sapersi principi chiave non
fossimo vito era ragazzi